meine Mama macht die beste
chilomatensoße der Welt die benutzen wir
z.B immer ganz gerne zum Frühstück Brot
reindippen Käsesoße dazu perfekt dafür
nehmt ihr einfach ganz reife Tomaten die
reibt ihr mit der Küchenmaschine oder
mit einer Küchenreibe fein das ganze
kommt in einen Topf Chilischoten kurz
klein schneiden dazu geben und aufkochen
ich würze das ganze noch mit Salz
Pfeffer etwas Bohnenkraut und auch Minze
und dann kommt das ganze in sterile
abgekochte Gläser wird verschlossen und
ist so für mehrere Monate bis zu einem
Jahr haltbar und so habt ihr immer einen
Vorrat an Chili Tomatensoße